hey everyone diabolo here and in today's
video we are going to be going over more
of the absolutely wonderful and
excruciatingly beautiful world of the
one and only demon slayer going through
the story so far has been honestly
something that constantly keeps my eyes
peeled to the page for hours and hours
at a time without me even realizing
literally how much time has passed over
my past to explain videos i've gone over
probably two of the most hyped and
utterly insane arcs of the komitsu no
yaiba story that being the entertainment
district arc and the swordsmith village
arc so just before we continue on with
the story if you want to be up to date
with everything that has happened so far
then do be sure to check out those
videos which i will leave a link to down
in the description below also i just
want to cut myself off here again i
think this cements my spot as an
official youtuber now as the big dogs
themselves the god of sponsorships raid
shadow legions has officially come in
and saved our day by sponsoring this
video you may not know this but
raid has actually got a ton of champions
and if you love world building as much
as myself then be sure to go and check
out raid's world and how each character
comes from its own unique faction with
an added level of immersion as they've
also added an in-depth history inside of
its own unique world called talaria
check out my links below to download
raid yourself on pc or mobile but if
you're still somehow not convinced the
newest boss just released in raid and
it's one of the biggest and craziest yet
this thing is literally a hydra with a
total of six different heads each one of
these heads itself is a complete boss
battle all on its own for example the
one i found the most painful so far is
the head of decay like this thing has
attacks but the main reason it is hard
is the anti-heal components of this boss
as i constantly love having full health
in like every game i play but every time
you heal or try to heal one of your
champions while fighting against the
head of a decay it does the complete
opposite and actually makes you lose max
hp which is just painful in my opinion
or the head of suffering like once again
in the name you will suffer it's got
this new effect called pain link which
literally lets the head share the damage
it takes with you if you're not careful
you'll end up dying insanely quickly so
i'd personally recommend you bring along
someone who can end up tanking the
pain-linked debuff to get around this
effect and if the craziest hydra boss
and the entirety of mobile games isn't
enough for you there's more raid is also
giving away a super limited edition
champion to every single player it's the
esports legend navi superstar simple
between now and january 28th 2022
simple's limited edition champ is
available for free to both new and old
players in raid all you have to do is
log in for seven days between now and
january 28th and is yours if you missed
that date though then you miss out
forever so just to make an account and
claim them through my link on top of
that there's a ton of new year's events
and tournaments including a special
fusion event where you can get one of
rave's newest legendary champions and if
you use my link in the description or
scan the qr code that is currently on
screen you'll get a free starter pack
with almost 30 usd to kickstart your
game we're talking a free champion
tariel 200 000 in silver one energy
refill one xp boost and one ancient
shards so you can summon awesome
champions as soon as you get in the game
all the treasure will be waiting for you
and the chest icon so make sure you
click that right here once you're in the
game you can find me under the name
diavolo yt and it's literally that easy
so just click the link in the
description below and you'll see the
game but anyway continuing on with this
story we finally come to a special
training session that aims to improve
all demon slayers abilities and health
this here is the one and only hashera
training arc of demon slayer but just
before we dive head first into this arc
which leaves us on the largest
cliffhanger of the entire series so far
if you are new around here and want more
explained videos just like this one then
do be sure to hit that subscribe button
and also be sure to leave a like on the
video as it really helps out with the
algorithm and pushes my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people but anyway enough
of that let's get into the hashera
training arc
so after niziko's sudden change and the
end of the battle between the two demons
we find that there have been plans to
move the swordsmith village due to the
battle these planes were set into action
right away as come nightfall the demons
would undoubtedly attack once again we
also find out that even though two upper
ranked demons had attacked the village
its damages in general had been kept to
a minimum because of the work that the
slayers had put in
back at the hideout tanjulo chats with
goto the kikushi at the butterfly
mansion after waking up from resting for
seven days straight after the fight goto
tells tanjido that these swordsmiths
have several empty villages that have
been prepared in case of emergencies
like this after chatting some more goto
says that he wanted to especially ask
tanjido something
which was that he'd heard something
incredible happen to neziko nonchalantly
tanjuli replies that she is now walking
around in the sun commenting on the
complete absurdity of the situation
while he continues to stuff his face
then without thinking tangier slips up
and tells gotho that tamiyo is looking
into why and how nezuko has conquered
the sun because goto doesn't know who
tamiya is he questions him on this
causing tangero to choke on his food
distracting goto from the topic as goto
jokes about how everything will be
peaceful until zenitsu shows up it
suddenly cuts to the yellow-haired
maniac arriving at the butterfly mansion
after a mission and finding out that
nezuko can now walk in the sun and speak
zineshu screams out loud and says that
he's having a heart attack and grabbing
niziko before screaming more about how
cute and absolutely amazingly wonderful
and marvelous it is that nizika was able
to be out in the sun he screams at her
to please marry him then she utters the
words welcome back inosuke zenesu's mood
immediately changes as he says that he
is going to burn inosuke alive and then
quickly explains that enosuke had
visited the butterfly mansion a few days
ago and made it his mission to make sure
that nezuko could say his name later
that same day an emergency pillow
meeting was held at the ubyashiki estate
sunimi aguro muchuro matsuri gyome
shinobu and giyu are all present after
the hashera greet each other a main
ubishiki kagai's wife makes her
appearance in place of her husband as
his illness has left him completely
beard ridden and unable to move the
stonehishiro gyome immediately bows to
the ground after he hears this
information and says that he prays from
the bottom of his heart for his master's
life to continue to burn even if it was
for only one more day
once the meeting begins a man brings up
the information about a certain demon
who has managed to conquer the sun
obviously referring to the stunning
mexico she says that because of this
they will soon find themselves in a
full-scale war
after a while she brings up these
strange marks that appeared on matsuri
and muchiro that day and amane explains
what they are these are marks that many
of the first swordsmen who were only one
step away from beating muzan head they
had all manifested marks similar to
demonic patterns this information had
been hidden due to the fact that many
people brooded over not actually having
the marks over time the information had
become unclear but one thing that was
passed on indefinitely was that whoever
had the mark would start spreading it to
others who fit the qualifications a main
thing says that the first person to
manifestly mark did not have the rank of
a sharer instead the first person to
gain this mark in generations was no one
other than tanjido
though when they asked him how he felt
when he had got the mark he had
absolutely no idea so they decided to
not pursue him for it but now that two
more people have gained the mark maine
asks them to teach the rest of them how
it was done
sadly can roger had a hard time putting
into words and only embarrasses herself
when all she can do is come up with
vague descriptions that are mostly made
up of noises about how it felt but
maturo does have some kind of idea about
what could possibly cause the mark to
appear on anyone
muchiro explains that during his fight
he got poisoned so he used breathing to
slow his blood circulation then a boy
who tried to help him almost got killed
and he began to remember his past
memories he became so consumed by his
anger that he lost complete control of
his emotions he says that he thinks his
heart rate exceeded 200 beats per minute
and his body temperature went over 39
degrees celsius mature continues saying
that those who do not have the mark
appear even though they do have the
qualifications do not get the mark
because they will die but those whose
bodies can withstand the extreme
circumstances will having mark appear
and enhance their ability to fight
confused about the specificities amine
asks what made him think that his
temperature was 39 degrees in which
maturity says that when he was 9 shinobi
was treating his wounds he was reported
to have a fever at 39 degrees and he
says that he felt the exact same way
when the mark appeared after everyone
reacts to how they will try to gain the
mark amane says that there is one thing
she must tell everyone regarding
manifesting the mark she states for
those who have already manifested the
mark it is too late those who do not
manifest the mark without any exception
we'll all
a mane then leaves as the pillars are
about to have a discussion about
training tomioka stands up and claims
that there is no need or reason that he
has to stay any longer this then leaves
the other pillars confused as to why he
doesn't think he needs to be there but
his only explanation is that he is
different from them completely
aggravated by this shinozugawa says that
he does not buy that and asks tomioka if
he looks down on the other hasheras
tomioku doesn't explain himself or what
he means which causes zanimi to strike
at him but as this happens the stone
pillar and complete beast kyomei says
that they should all sit down and
continue talking as he has a proposal it
then cuts to hagenizuka who has arrived
at the butterfly mansion to deliver
tanjido his reforged sword while he
struggles for air sweat pours off the
mask of the swordsman suddenly
haganezuka whips out tanjido's new sword
which has ring goku's health firmly
attached then gives it to him and at the
request of goto he sits down before
urging tanjido to unsheath the blade
tanjuno is left in complete awe by the
beauty of the blade and haganezuka says
that it is made from high quality steel
and must have been used previously by a
very strong swordsman the blade has the
character for sleigh pronounced mitsu
which can also mean destruction and the
japanese language haganezuka also
explains that this blade was probably
made before the demon hierarchy was ever
established and this was why many of the
hashera have the kanji pronounced aki
misatsu engraved on their blades which
means destroy all evil demons in the
japanese language tangido then says that
he did not remember seeing those words
on these swords when he had used it
quickly hakanesuka is set into an angry
monologue on how tanjaro has put
irremovable damage on the blade because
he had used it while it was still in the
early stages of sharpening the blade he
then leaves after tanjudo promises him
to bring him dumplings until the day he
dies overhearing the commotion an
annoyed genius then complains about how
noisy tangido and his guests were
tanjito apologises and goes on to say
that he is done but he doesn't get to
finish because inosuke enters the room
by breaking through the window
completely destroying it in the process
the shirtless ball boy then relentlessly
begins screaming out loud that it is
here group strength training starts now
as a large group of demon slayers are
seen heavily sweating they run down and
through a mountain pass it is explained
through zenitsu that this special
training known as hashira training had
begun this training was to ensure that
those who are ranked lower than the
hashera get to actually train with each
individual pillar in a different order
to strengthen the demon slayers this is
actually a special exercise because
generally hashera would only train with
their successors but since niziko's
sudden change the demon's appearances
have completely stopped leaving heshira
to do their security details by night
and focus on training the demon slayers
during the day after hearing all this
information tanjuro happily remarks that
it is amazing but zunitsu instantly cuts
him off and tells him that it is not
amazing at all and instead it is awful
it is complete hell tanjuro retorts
though saying that sparring with someone
who is stronger than you is the best way
to quickly improve and that when you
face them you can absorb wisdom through
the fight to also get stronger yourself
hearing this zenetsu strikes out and
bites down on tangero's head screaming
at him and telling him that they are no
longer friends as of right now then goes
to leave tanjuro tries to stop him and
eventually zanetsu turns around to hear
tanjudo tell him that during his fight
with the upper rank he had used the
trick that he had taught him for thunder
breathing he tries to use this to get
sunitsu to realize that this is how
connections with other people help you
get through tight spots so everything he
learns during the sashira training will
eventually pay off for him in the future
again instantly zinetsu's mood
completely shifts from upset to an
overjoyed who tries telling
chanchito that this doesn't change his
mood at all while he sprints out of the
room a random crow comes flying into the
room through a window and hits tangido
directly in the forehead he then gives
tanjuro a letter as it skips away from
the mysterious letter we find ourselves
with the flashiest lord our retired god
the big man tengan uzoi tengan screams
at the younger slayers who are training
under him for being late and says that
they are barely even able to run
screaming at them to stop licking the
ground while he smashes down on them
with his bokuto it then reveals to us
the positioning ichishira has taken in
training the younger slayers with tengen
and his grueling basic fitness workouts
being the first trial followed by
lessons by matsuri in flexibility and to
keto and high speed movement then comes
swordsmanship with his serpent hashera
and lessons in making infinite strikes
with the wind finally finishing with the
ultimate strength training session with
the stoneheshira gyome with this
constant sparring going on for hours at
end it should further improve the
heshira's overall strength and if this
somehow grants the right conditions for
manifesting their mark that would also
be perfectly ideal as for people who
have already manifested the mark they
just need to maintain their condition
hopefully with all that has been learned
among every member it will also raise
the overall strength of the actual core
itself in preparation for the
up-and-coming battle as it flashes away
from the explanation we find tomioka
sitting alone
suddenly tanjiro shows up and without
any hesitation makes his entrance into
giulio's house leaving tomioka
completely stunned at the random
scenario after tanjudo explains the
training session to the water shearer he
tells him that in seven days he will be
able to return to active duty and would
like for tomioka to train him in which
he denies tomioka explains that he is
not angry but more that he was supposed
to become the new water hashira tanjunu
apologizes saying that he spoke to
urakudaki about breathing styles and how
it isn't unusual that sometimes you can
change your breathing style and give
birth to a new one he states that the
water breathing techniques especially
are close to the basics so they help
give rise to many new styles bakiu tells
tanjiro to not say that because there is
currently no water hashera so someone
must fill that role as soon as possible
confused tanju asks him about this to
what she is told that giu tomioka is not
the water heshira
as tanjiro sits there stunned he thinks
back to the letter he received earlier
this letter was from kagaya yubishiki
and he specifically had asked tanjido to
go and talk to giyu as he doesn't think
he can do so in his current state gagaya
tells him that this is an incredibly
important time where everyone must come
together becky you goes at things alone
as he remembers the master's words he
reiterates the thought that he will be
persistent and continuously talk to geru
he constantly hung around him and talked
non-stop to the point that geyu was left
completely complexed wondering if this
would go on for the rest of his life
after a painful four days geru
eventually gave in and revealed that he
hadn't passed the final selection exam
giu explained that a boy like him named
sabito had taken the final selection at
the same time as him cebito had killed
all of the demons almost completely
alone and yet somehow ended up failing
where in a complete contrast giyu had
been injured by the first demon and
fallen into a daze the next thing he
knew was that the exam was over and that
he had somehow survived giu tells
tanjiro that he thinks he isn't worthy
of becoming a hashera because of this he
doesn't even feel like he should stand
near his other pillars as he feels like
he doesn't really deserve a place in the
demon slayer core as he begins to walk
away from tangido he states that he will
not manifest the mark although sabito
may have so don't bother him anymore as
it is a complete waste of time tanjo
thinks to himself about guillot's
feelings and how he bet that he wishes
that he'd died in sabito's place he
realizes he understands that feeling so
well that it hurts noting that when
someone is so important to you that you
wish you could die in their place it
feels like you're being ripped apart
from the inside he begins to remember
about sabito and makomo who had trained
him even though they were supposedly
dead as he compares himself to sabito
tanju admires him for being able to
protect and save everyone else at the
final selection while tanjuro himself
could not and he remarks that sibiso
would have become a formidable swordsman
had he survived which is obviously
another reason that may gear you feel
like he'd be better off dead instead
tangido understanding his emotions
remembers kyojiro who had also lost his
life to protect him in his mind tangible
too believes that the flame hashera
could have become someone capable enough
to defeat muzan and that he wishes he
could have died in his place
pondering on what to tell giu he
eventually decides to ask giu a question
regarding whether or not he wants to
exploit what sabato entrusted to him
which leaves the supposed water
hersheira completely stunned by
tanjido's question the important
memories of his past suddenly began to
come flooding back into ghihu's mind the
supposed water hashera recalls his past
with sabito slapping him and telling him
to never say that he'd wished he died
sebiso went on and insisted that gilu
had to live to protect others so not to
disrespect his sister who had lost her
life from protecting him from a demon
back in the present in his mind gee
apologizes to both sibiso and his sister
for being so immature and forgetting
this basic morale as tangelo stands
there observing a silent gilu he
believes he could have made a mistake
for asking the question and comes up
with the idea of having an eating
contest which may solve the issue after
finally deciding to train with tangido
gui turns around and before his words
could reach him tangero suggests that
the two have an eating contest and much
to his initial confusion the water
hashera ends up accepting elsewhere the
insect teshira shinobu can be seen
running through the corridors of the
butterfly mansion as she sits down in
front of an altar she tells herself to
calm down as only the immature can't
handle their emotions leaving her
pondering the idea that she's probably
immature as she slumps saddened at the
overall situation alway welcomes her
back to a room announcing herself at the
same time before asking her if it was
possible to train with a stonehishera
shinobu tells her that she can't help it
with training this time to the confusion
of aoi when she is told to come closer
she tells shinobu that she would like to
train with her samoa which brings up the
overall mood of shinobu who tells kanua
that she has gotten much better at
speaking her mind still confused aoi
asks if this wasn't the right time but
to her visible surprise shinobi retorts
telling her that it is now time to talk
about how to kill the demon who killed
her sister kane
far away a crow calls as it flies
through the night and makes its entrance
into the top room of tamiyo's household
warning her that it is dangerous to
leave her windows open at night
the crow then introduces himself as
kagaya yubishiki's messenger and tells
tamio that she was extremely good at
hiding herself so good in fact that the
crow's master had lost the ability to
completely move during the time it had
taken to find her after some more
conferring between the two the crow
begins telling tamio about their plan
which is that they would like for her to
come to the ube yoshiki mansion to help
study musico and finally help defeat the
one and only muzan kevitsuji as tamio's
heart races her thoughts also race
through her head as she ponders how even
though she's a demon they have asked for
her to come to the main hideout to help
having recovered from his battle against
hantengu tangelo joined the joint
training effort he is greeted by tengen
and his wives whose training he
completes in just 10 days he then
travels to muchiro's residence who
complimented him on having even faster
swords play and who also sought to
increase his stamina via helping his
muscles ease and tense up more smoothly
having accomplished this muchero
cheerfully allowed tanjiro to move on to
the next teshira training despite its
only having been five days the next day
shira to train tangido was matsuri who
exchanged some pleasantries with the
youth before they got down to the task
at hand and they love hashira's training
they mendeus up in a manner reminiscent
of ballerinas and dance constantly at
the same time she helps them improve
their flexibility with her own strength
this led to the next place of tanjuno's
training with the serpent hashera obanai
after an unpleasant greeting from his
superior tanger was thrust into his
variation of the ordeal with room being
covered and bound swordsmen on the floor
and walls expected to deliver blows to
obani while avoiding striking these
unfortunate souls during the training
between the two tangier was struck by
his teacher whose blows were able to
weave like a snake between the tied up
individuals despite these hardships
which included being able to hear the
terrified victims begged not to be hit
tangier eventually began to counter and
avoid overnight strikes after four days
of hard work after striking off the
heyori the hashera was wearing he was
permitted to go into the next section of
the training with the windhashera sunimi
shinozugawa on his way there he
encounters a visibly terrified zinetsu
who had fled from the intense and brutal
tutelage however as he screams for
tanchito to help him escape saneemie
catches up with him grabbing his head
and threatening him to return him to the
facility before ultimately knocking him
out tsunami then forces tanjido to carry
his unconscious friend while running
behind the hashera the two exchange
harsh words with each other affirming
their hatred that they have towards each
other after the training ended it was
revealed that shinozugawa's training was
so grueling that he understood wazinitsu
had become so rabid he goes on to say
that it was just a simple striking
exercise where he would attack sunimi
each session continued without rest
until he ended up vomiting blood and
eventually passing out once he awoke
zinitzu cursed him and tanjura realized
that shinozugawa was overly tough on
tangio to the point that if he lost
concentration for a moment he would have
gotten seriously injured still
incredibly beat up from all of this
training while walking back to his room
tangero then witnessed sanimi and his
little brother it was obvious genya was
trying his hardest to talk with his
brother but despite this kenya gets
threatened by the hashera who insisted
that he had no brother and if he didn't
knock this off then he would kill him
leaving genya standing there saddened
and completely speechless as tanjudo
listens in on the attention-filled
confrontation between the shinozugawa
brothers sunimi straightforwardly
disowns genya as his brother distraught
by this denial and his brother's lack of
empathy ginyu further tries to apologize
for his wrong doing while being secretly
encouraged by tanjido who was
eavesdropping and reveals his
desperation to where he acquired the
ability to fight by eating demons
tsunemi stops in his tracks and pairs
back menacingly at genya questioning his
words about eating demons he vanishes
within the moment causing tanjiro to
make a break towards kenya to tackle him
to the ground safely protecting him from
having his eyes gouged out by sanemi the
two boys crashed through the sliding
door into the outside garden scaring
zanetsu along with the other demon
slayers tangero questioned sunimi for
trying to kill his brother but the
latter corrected him stating that he
will only beat genya until he has no
longer the ability to regenerate
resulting in his retirement from the
demon slayers in disbelief tangero
defended genya stating that he was
instrumental in defeating the upper rank
during their last encounter and declared
that he will protect him from his
brother who disowned him sunimi then
turned to attack tanjuro patanjaro was
able to block his punch and counter
attack once the brawl between tangier
and tsunami started tanjuno quickly
requests to zunetsu to take genya away
with him doing so straight away but as
the netsu takes kenya away he insults
his brother which results in kenya
smacking zinetsu over their head
everything turned into a mess from that
point onwards and the chaos continued
all the way until the late evening
tangido got an official scolding from
the higher-ups and his training with the
windhashera not only came to a halt but
he was also banned from ever approaching
him in the end tanjaro was unable to
help mediate and repair the
shinozugawa's brother's relationship as
the bruised tanjido and zanitsu make
their way to the stonehenge training
ground they find inosuke and the other
demon slayers training under a waterfall
and are greeted by the stonehishira who
was close by meditating in a hellish way
this ended up resulting with zinitzu
screaming out as he sees that the
hashera was standing barefoot and a pet
of fire guilemi begins explaining the
importance of his training as
stabilizing one's body with strong limbs
will lead to accurate attacks and an
industrious defense his training module
included three simple things first
training by having the waterfall beat
down on you second carry three logs on
your shoulders and finally push a
massive boulder over one show which if
in a normal measurement would usually be
around 0.1 meters as one square meter is
approximately 100.83
cho despite the training seeming easy it
was actually horrendous and constantly
zanetsu kept on complaining about the
freezing waterfall even anosuke who was
working hard ended up drowning after
reviving his friend tanjiro also trained
under the waterfall and realized that
the chance taught by gyome with her
focusing and informing the others that
he is still conscious while eating
grilled fish together with the other
demon slayers inosuke asserted that the
rock hashera is the strongest in their
organization
tangero supported this as he also
noticed that kyomei is the only one with
a different scent of smell zenitsu on
the other hand was still in disbelief
that gyome was able to move the boulder
easily but was dumbfounded when he saw
the hashera pushing an even bigger rock
eventually tanjuro and his friends were
able to complete the waterfall and log
carrying training but they were still
unable to push the boulder in any kind
of way guillermo's training was hard but
it wasn't completely compulsory if you
wanted to quit you could always go down
the mountain and give up six more days
passed and tanjido was still unable to
move his boulder and despite all his
training the mark still didn't show up
while tanjo was contemplating about the
current situation genya suddenly
appeared and asked about tanjuro's scar
noting that it is getting bigger he then
told tanjido what happened to him after
the scuffle with his brother he got
himself scolded by gyome and it was told
to never go near sunimi again apparently
genya was also on the rock training and
compared to tanjo he was able to move
his boulder which led him to question
the latter if he knew about repeating
actions he then explained that kyomei
sucks at teaching so one must watch him
closely in order to not fail at passing
his training ginyu goes on to explain
that gyome was actually doing a
predetermined set of movements in order
to maximize his concentration guyme can
be seen eavesdropping while the two
continue talking about repeating actions
elsewhere the demon eyeballs are quietly
stalking a lone demon slayer as he walks
through the streets the eyes turn out to
be nakimese who were spying on the
whereabouts of the demon slayers while
she and muzan stay hidden inside the
infinity castle she states that she has
determined the location of about 60 of
all of the demon slayers but she has
still absolutely no idea about the
location of the girl who conquered the
sun she reports her findings to muzan
who praises her growth and quietly
states that he will soon find both
niziko and ubishiki
according to what genya taught tanjiro
repetitive action is a technique that
opens all five senses kenya may not be
able to use breaths but he can achieve
total concentration another way which is
through these repetitive actions when
gyome and genya use it they remember
their anger and painful memories that
makes their heart rate and temperature
go up the signs were pointing to the
possibility that this might be the same
as tanjiro's mark coming out but gyome
and genya had no marks so they cocked
their heads in confusion by doing these
repetitive actions you can focus on any
given movement and tangible thought how
it would be nice if he could learn how
to maintain his darkened mark forever
his repetitive actions were remembering
all of the faces of his loved ones then
recalling rengoku's words keep your
heart burning and with that he was able
to raise his focus to its maximum limits
tangero couldn't do it at the very
beginning but he was able to use all the
strength that he had by doing these
repetitive actions as he did them again
and again his body began to remember the
way to bring out that power through this
specific set of actions eventually he
was able to push the boulder slowly but
surely surprised by tajiro's sudden
growth inosuke immediately jumps into
action and by thinking about the rock as
tempura he was able to push it some
distance as azinitsu looks in dismay at
howie is the only one remaining to move
the boulder suddenly a sparrow appears
next to him chirping and holding a
letter tangier was able to move his
boulder across one cho finishing the
rock hishera's training but was left
completely dehydrated by this task as he
writhes in pain on the ground kiyomi
walks up and pours water over tanjido he
then accepts him as a swordsman
recalling tanjiru's actions from the
swordsmith village when he prioritized
the villages over his younger sister's
life during the crisis tanjido however
did not accept this praise as nezuko was
the one who had made that decision and
not him upon hearing this guyme knows
that how different tanjuro is as to him
children are pure and naive weak quick
to lie completely fine with cruelty and
selfish little things gyome then begins
to tell tanjido his story about how he
raised some kids who had no family in a
temple before he became a demon slayer
their affirmative and having no blood
connections helped them bond together
very well and he raised them like his
own family gyomi wanted to keep life
that way forever but then one night a
kid disobeyed the temple's rules and
didn't come back after sunset and sadly
ran into a demon in order to save his
own skin the boy told the demon the
location and the number of people inside
the temple he also so that the demon
made it past the temple's defenses put
out all of the wisteria and sensed that
gyome had burning as protection and
invited the demon inside the temple
which resulted in four kids dying
immediately as they got sliced in half
yami tried to protect the other four but
they did not listen to him so they tried
to run and sadly died only sayo the
youngest listened to him and hid behind
him in order to protect sayo gyomo
fought and punched the demon's head
again and again until the sun came up he
was able to protect sayo but when people
came to help saya was only four years
old at that time and got confused and
labelled gourmet as a murderer and a
monster who had killed all of the
children as a result guyme was
imprisoned and charged with murder if
kagaya had not intervened he would have
been executed and ever since he had come
to harbor deep doubts and suspicions
that no matter how virtuous you are once
you get pushed into a corner your true
nature will come out but tangido never
ran he always stayed honest and never
lied seeing that tanjaro indeed as a
special child hyomi promised him to help
so that tangido would not make a wrong
turn in his life
after this he then told tanjido that he
had officially finished his training
with the stonehishera later on while
eating together ginyu recalls to tanjuro
how gyome made him his disciple despite
the fact that he doesn't have the talent
to be an apprentice and guessed that he
was actually eating demons as a way to
get stronger guillermo introduced ginya
to shinobu for her to check up honest
conditions but every time he sees her
she puts on a disgusted face and scolds
kenya tanjuro however comments that
shinobu was just worried about ginya's
body and invited him to go see geyu
together to talk about his brother once
they are done 18. but kenya declines as
he is still not finished with the rock
hisher is training saying that he was
still yet to move the boulder one cho
while on his way to giu tanjiro saw
zanitsu on top of his boulder and asked
if he would be okay since they have not
talked for a while which worried him
zenith tells tanjito that he has simply
achieved clarity about what he should do
what he must do tanjiru tries to pull
more information out of zenitsu but all
he manages to get was that he must do
what he must do
still before leaving zanetsu ends up
slightly caving in and thanks him
telling tanjido that he is truly a nice
guy
but standing there with the most
determined look of his life he
reiterates that there is something that
he absolutely must do
tangier then visits giu's place and upon
his arrival he saw geyu and tsunemi
fight him with wooden swords on hand
their movements are so fast but he notes
that he can follow their movements the
battle ended with both geyu and
tsunimi's swords broken after a clash of
breathing techniques and tsunami
suggested that they continued their
fight with their fists suddenly tangido
then interrupted them and suggested that
they just share some ohagi which pissed
off saneemie even more given that him
and tangelo are not supposed to get near
each other after the group awkwardly
have somewhat of a passive aggressive
conversation tsunami storms off after
and giu notes that every heshera also
takes part in each other's training he
also plans to sneak some ohagi into a
bag to give to sunimi in order to try
and get along with him whilst anime is
walking angrily away from geyu's place
he notices something following him
nearby and the foliage and instantly
snatches it from the ground then
proceeds to crush it in his fingers as
it falls from his hand it confused
sunimi wonders what it could possibly be
elsewhere at the exact same time the
meeting of generations is about to take
place
under the starry moonlit night kagaya
yubishiki welcomes muzan kibijutsu to
his household as their first ever
meeting commences
as the demon muzan slowly closes in on a
beard-red and ubishiki he tells him that
he looks in an unsightly condition
before
well that officially brings us to the
very end of the one and only hashira
training arc of demon slayer if you guys
have enjoyed the video then make sure
you do hit that subscribe button and
also be sure to leave a like on the
video as well as it really does help out
with that algorithm and pushes my stuff
to a bunch of new amazing people so
obviously this is like the third part of
my entire demon slayer story explained
so far
or explained in general um the next one
is going to be on the entire infinity
castle part of the final arc i'm not
sure if i'm going to put the final arc
in three parts yet but i know that i'll
most likely have the affinity arc as
like one whole video itself or the
infinity castle like whatever you like
to call it um this story so far has been
absolutely amazing and enjoyed every
single part of it the training arc was a
nice little break in between all of the
action that we have been having recently
so you know i've really enjoyed just
seeing a lot of the uh the character
building that we have got throughout
this i really want to know what's going
on with zenitsu obviously because this
is like still a
blind like read-through i guess for me i
don't know what is going to happen in
this infinity castle arc that is coming
up next so i can't wait to actually get
into that and read it you know uh in the
up and coming chapters or i can't wait
to actually get into that and read that
in the uh up and coming you know like
chapters that are uh after this one and
the final one but yeah as i said before
if you are new around here make sure you
hit that subscribe button and also be
sure to hit that like as it really helps
out with the algorithm and pushes my
stuff to a bunch of new amazing people
and also make sure you go down below and
check out raid which you you know you
can get through my link like i said
earlier in the video as honestly it
helps out more than you can like imagine
sponsoring these kind of videos it means
that i can put more time into them and
uh like if you can support them they can
help support me so make sure you go and
check them out it is free so just go and
do it boys but anyway for now it's been
your professional degenerate diavolo and
i will see you all in a bit bye
you